i i got shot down
uh a few weeks before that i got shot my
mind the sky
80 bullet holes through the plane killed
a fellow on the ground shot the
shot the leg nearly off the man was
all right a little nine hundred foot
strip there peachy linga poor
poor village with starving donkeys
that's where they'd i'd give them
seventeen thousand dollars for a load
and i'd go over on the highway and load
well on day 13
i did a load every day for 13 days they
had a bunch of marijuana pretty good
piled up and i was going low today
and uh on day 13 i had that little
warning sign going off in my stomach
don't do it
but i asked this walking oh we had the
federalists paid off know where we were
so i spent the night
in a hammock and walked down to the
airplane
just as it did in daylight and 10 or 12
men walked with me and pedro got
and i brushed my teeth into the little
stream was about foot deep
little river coming through there got in
the airplane and uh
i fired her up and bam
i thought a tire blew out i looked over
and sees
it still ain't dawned on me and pedro's
yelling please see ya please see it
rocha please see ya
well it dawned on me and i shoved it the
throttle to the firewall and i only had
so that was a bullet
yeah somebody they there's off to the
side they'd shot they'd shot just
a warning like get out stop we're gonna
rob you
whatever it is that's what they do it's
taken the plane and me and put me in
prison the whole thing so
but i even though i had papers so uh i
just shoved it to firewall and there
wasn't enough room to take off on that
strip
and there's half of it was behind me or
some of it was behind me
and so just at the end i'm just like i
think that thing stalls at about 50
miles an hour just
just turning 50 and i just pulled it
right up
and put the flaps on and as i pulled off
the ground
they opened up on both sides of me with
machine guns and they
riddled that airplane i mean the
windshield came out i got hit three
times
uh do you like your body yeah and uh
uh i didn't know i was hit i mean it was
just the
adrenaline the gasoline just pouring in
the world turned yellow i must have went
into shock
so it just stopped in slow motion and uh
one bullet hit the strut right by my
head and it just
uh parts of that bullet just went all
over me i just looked like i'd been
peppered which would uh lead
and uh the gasoline would just pour in
and i'm just pouring in where they'd
shot the wing up above
and the windshield's gone i didn't i
mean i i didn't know blah blah blah blah
blah
blah it's just like like a hailstorm
so i uh i with airplanes the staller now
it i was in a stall anyway and i didn't
realize it and i guess you wouldn't
unless you trained for it
but when you're in a stall the elevator
is kind of flappy
and i didn't realize that time i thought
they had shot the elevator cable in too
so i thought oh god so i just reached
over and switched it off switched to
pull the mixture pulled everything and
uh
in the river there was rocks about as
big as this table and they were
like the turtle back all the way up
until there was a waterfall there was
quite a pretty place
and i crashed straight on to it i
thought if i get those rocks
and when i did the first time i hit the
wings came off and then it bounced
and the next time the nose came out and
came under the plane
and i'm sitting there i must have been
knocked unconscious called pedro's
shaking me come on roger come on roger
so i stepped out into the water and here
comes these four federalists still
shooting at us
and i'm bullied the two hit the airplane
and
i kept a nine millimeter browning high
power taped to the top of the radio
in case i ever needed it so because
you're one of those times
didn't want it in the airplane so i just
it was just handy just laying there so i
took and popped a few caps on them
and they ran into the rocks so uh
we took off up off running and then i
looked and pedro's foot nearly shot off
had shot him on
one side the ankle and it just blown out
the other side and it wasn't even hardly
bleeding it
the shock of it so i took my t-shirt off
and gripped it and
tied it best i could yeah it's still
bullets in you so like you could just
i shot the top of my toenail off yeah i
shot a job across my head in my kneecap
so i was just nicked okay it was very
painful later on but right that time i
didn't
it was it was just hot there's a bullet
stealing my foot from it a piece of a
bullet
good sized slug so we went on up the
mountain through the cactus
and just running just going i want to go
down no no avail federalists are going
to
the easy way let's go this young fellow
and we came to an old donkey
she must have been 30 years old long and
way back
long hair on her charlotte charlotte and
he petted the donkey and we jumped on
and we wrote for an actual donkey donkey
they were donkeys all over the place
anyhow he knew that was from the village
and so we rode seven miles two of us on
a donkey with no bridle no saddle
nothing
and uh we came to a little man plowing a
little
horse and a little ox there's both of
them spotted and there's the ox was
the yoke was across their back this way
and he's plowing with a little plow
amongst stumps
it was like one of these people clearing
a little piece of land and he had a
little little house there
and so we went in his house and his wife
and his daughter they put like a
cloth over my wounds and on pedro's it
was terrible was terrible
and they poured diesel oil on to keep
the flies off
so i'm covered in diesel so the man left
and he was going all day and then about
dark he showed up about 15 or 20 horses
and mules showed up in the yard walking
fast and the doctor got out he said i'm
dr benjamin so-so with red cross
and he worked on my foot and he worked
on pedro he gave us a shot of morphine
and
tetanus shots and he said you got to get
to hospital
he said pedro will die if he don't get
to hospital he said they're looking for
american pilots been shot down they
think he's dead there was a lot of blood
in that airplane
and so they rode i don't know how far we
rode but we rode miles and we'd come to
a road and there was a big truck
it was loaded with corn in the ear and
they dug holes in that corn
put us in it and covered us up and the
road was rough and every time we'd hit a
dirt road that corn would cover me up
and they'd scratch my face out again
and when it came to the highway we went
into a house and they got me some
clothes and mine was messed up
and uh white basin and they must have
brought 20
jugs of water different times i kept
washing them washing my foot till
all the blood and the crud got off of me
and put on those clothes
and somebody went to uh they said you
can't go north the roads block they're
looking for the pilot
so you got to go south so they found a a
taxi in
mazatlan and it was a rather new taxi
and the fellow would
would take me to guadalajara which was i
don't know seven eight hours
south so we got in that taxi and they
propped me up with sheets and blankets
and
pillows in the back seat and gave me
these great big white
pain pills and i was quite content
then i was shot down and shot down in
columbia also
what uh can you tell that story i sure
can
all right i was i went down for lowdom a
little marijuana
and we got to the place and we got there
too early
and the gorillas screamed you got to get
out of here got to get out of here
and so we went back to the place where
we staged from and
refueled had a beautiful dc3 carried
three tons
and uh so while i was waiting
i uh
i ate something for lunch and i went
around behind the house we refueled the
plane up i had to wait till late now
they wanted me to come just at dark so
the military planes couldn't see me on
their strip
so i'm laying in the hammock asleep and
i hear this terrible roar
and i looked right up through the trees
and the ascent of two
military jets going straight up
and they do a dive over and they came
back down the strip in front of that
airplane
and they just tear it up with 50 caliber
machine guns they just showing out
yeah so i run for the airplane i just
give that guy 80 000
and he ran for the truck and all the
rest of them ran for the truck i should
have ran with my money
but i didn't i ran for the airplane yeah
and uh the co-pilot got in the name was
al
he got in with me and two fellows got in
the back we had drums of fuel in there
to refuel when we got down
to the gorillas so we took off
and i couldn't get the gear up because
i'd taken off in such a hurry these
these pins in the struts of a dc-3 and
with big flags on them
and you have to take them up so that the
plant plane won't come up
so these jets swarmed on me and they
tried to get me to go they kept telling
me which way to go
and the pilot would be just as close as
just right over there i could see him
i just held up the old hippie piece i
didn't think they would shoot
i really didn't it nobody had shot
before
so i kept flying out and i kept getting
slower and slower and they kept slowing
down
down down and the black smoke rolling
and then they
they started shooting up under me boom
boom boom boom with them 20
millimeter counters and then and the
tracer just going up they look like
they're curving up
from you know whoa and i pushed the nose
over so they couldn't get under me and
later on i heard they thought i tried to
ram them so uh
one of them went for fuel and i kept on
going and the one
just tore the left wing wingtip up with
a 50 caliber
and then he come back again and shot the
tail up he's warning me
and i tell that fella and now says you
know if you bring me enough water i
believe i can fly this thing
my mouth got quite dry
so i went on and uh i landed on a big
pasture
and uh it was huge pasture and it was
rougher than it looked and the wings
just flapped and i come to stop and
jumped out
and pull those tabs out and threw them
on the ground so i can get my
gear up and i understand that during the
1980 world series baseball game
that it says american dc-3 has just been
shot down by american jets
by colombian jets you know it's the
first plane shot down on reagan's new
war on drugs
but he's up he's up and away ladies and
gentlemen we'll keep you posted so i
took off again
and i went into a thunderstorm and they
climbed close to the mountains
so i spiraled up and every time i'd come
out that jet was there boom boom boom
and uh i'd go back into that that storm
hit
boom boom boom in there and at 20 000
feet i started icing up
so i went out one last time and he was
right there waiting he had me on radar
so i went back in and i kicked it over
and put it into a spin and went straight
down to 2000 feet
and come out under it and i was flying
along the uh
guava river and it was a
20 feet above the water it looked like a
pasture it was just
grass and i made several runs to tear
the grass down and it looked like it
felt hard
no dc3 weighs 30 000 pounds and i put it
down on the fifth run and i said all
right now we're going to land now
and as i see flew like close oh several
times i put the wheels down oh you put
the wheels down without landing miles
and just so i'm making it weird you know
so
so you okay so you're you're you're
being
tracked by a jet he's trying to sh well
before that i'm just like retelling this
story how insane it is
uh so he is he's trying to shoot you
down
and there's a thunderstorm that you're
escaping into
and then you do a spin down to what 2000
feet whatever you said
like somehow escaping all of this and
then you try to land on a
pasture on a giant heavy plane that
carries three tons
uh by uh touching down five or six times
to make a to make a landing strip for
yourself
yeah the grass is three or four feet
okay so it was really good after about
after a few times
so then just before it stopped i said
i'll take your feet off the brakes
he said i don't have my feet on the
brakes well i knew i had broken through
the crust
and i put full power on but it didn't
that old big plane just come on down and
it just did a hit
as it came to stop it did a headstand
90 degrees to the ground oh wow and the
engines
helped held it up and the nose and all
just crushed in right on us
we fell between the two seats to keep
from getting killed wow and when it come
to a stop
all that fuel was pouring out on those
hot engines and there was an escape
hatch at the top i just stepped out
took my suitcase with me
did it uh was there fire no fire the
plane left the plane there and the two
guys it was in the back one and broke
his thumb and
it was with the barrels and they had to
put a hoses
tie gas hoses together to shimmy down to
get out yeah
so that's an incredible story well let
me just tell you
i had a little bit more to it i learned
to fly with the idea of being
a missionary aviation fellowship pilot
fly the missionaries in and out of the
jungle yes well i went 11 days through
that jungle the rest of them went on
down the road and got went to prison
i said i i'll crawl on my belly six
months in here a year
eating snakes before i'm going down the
road so i went in there and
i was 11 days in the jungle and i
finally came to his place
and uh it had airplanes i kept asking
the indian don just die evie owns
i want to steal an airplane get out of
there and when i came to the place
i asked what is this place lovely place
it looked like honolulu
in world war ii with a runway there said
you don't know
this is loma linda headquarters for
missionary aviation fellowship
for the amazon and they flew me out wow
you